we've got a ton of updates on halo
infinite including the special edition
console already being on ebay plus there
are new location screenshots out for
starfield and we're going to talk about
each one my name is davonte chisholm and
you're watching gamespot news
let's start with the halo infinite
edition xbox series x that was announced
at opening night live it should come as
no surprise that the special console
sold out almost immediately having even
more restricted pre-order supply in the
normal console what is equally
unsurprising is the console is already
getting scalped months ahead of its
launch spotted by the mpd groups matt
piscatella on twitter scalpers have
started putting up their pre-orders for
the console on marketplaces like ebay
while the console's official list price
was 550 usd scalpers have been selling
them for 900 and up and what blows my
mind even though it shouldn't is that a
simple search on ebay will show that
some of these listings actually sold and
as you might expect scalpers are also
trying to flip pre-orders for the halo
series 2 elite controller that was also
announced at opening night live these
pre-orders are selling for not as huge
of a markup selling for roughly 280
instead of the original 200.
and before we continue with these halo
updates i just want to let you know that
if you're excited for elden ring well
tamar hussein got a chance to see it and
there is an awesome preview up on the
site right now and a video version
edited by lucy james so go check that
out when this video is done because man
it just it makes me want to get into the
genre what do i got to do to get the
patience to you know what let's let's
get back to halo
if you found yourself wondering why the
halo infinite campaign wasn't shown at
gamescom well in a blog post microsoft's
joseph staton said he quote definitely
hears the disappointment about it not
being shown at the showcase staten
explained that the dev team is now in
quote shutdown mode which means work on
the game's main features for launch is
finished and the studio is now fixing
the highest priority bugs this is a big
job that takes a lot of time and
resources and creating a new demo or
trailer to show off the campaign would
have slowed things down
and over on the multiplayer side of
things 343 industries also clarified how
halo infinite will handle xp in a tweet
community manager john yuntsvik said
quote playing and winning matches will
be challenges which will help players
progress through the battle pass even
though this means no per match xp at
launch you'll still always be
progressing through challenges and
therefore the battle pass unicefix at
launch comment about per match xp
suggests that this might change in the
future but that remains to be seen
adding to this halo infinite's head of
design jerry hook has classified a key
point about the sci-fi shooter's battle
pass system in a blog post hook said
quote first off i want to correct my own
language when discussing the battle pass
all up in our live stream i stated that
the battle pass system will always have
free and paid rewards available at each
tier this statement is incorrect for our
launch battle pass he continued quote so
while there isn't a free reward at every
tier there will be numerous free rewards
to acquire across the entirety of the
season's battle pass and yes we are
still allowing you to keep your battle
pass once the season is over they will
not expire
and in other xbox related news the mini
fridge is reportedly still on track to
be released this holiday
and that's it for that story no
solid release date just that window just
the good news that it hasn't been
delayed yet
but okay switching gears to star field
in a new video bethesda has shown a
behind-the-scenes glimpse at three of
the locations that players will be able
to visit narrated by the game's design
director the videos show off the united
colonies capital city of new atlantis
the pleasure city of neon and the
capital of the freestar collective
aquila new atlantis is described as a
metropolitan melting pot of cultures set
in a spaceport where players can
interact with a diverse cast of
characters aquila is a walled city and
for good reason as beyond its borders
lie predators that have been described
as being a cross between wolves and
velociraptors finally neon is a city
that was originally meant to be a
fishing planet but after a discovery of
a fish with psychotropic properties
plants changed a drug was synthesized
from the fish and once legalized neon
became a tourist attraction for people
looking to experience a new type of high
alright guys it's friday so let me know
in the comments what you're going to be
playing this weekend i mean it's double
xp weekend in knockout city you got the
call of duty vanguard alpha over on
playstation consoles you got choices but
before you do that definitely make sure
you check out that elden ring preview
because again
the game sounds great i gotta play i
gotta play the other games i gotta get
into this
[Music]
you